alarm in rheinland pfalz ein autofahrer
ist am dienstagmittag in die trierer
fußgängerzone gefahren
laut polizei gab es mindestens zwei tote
und zehn verletzte
demnach sind die hintergründe noch
unklar
laut polizei wurde eine person
festgenommen laut zeugenaussagen seien
leute durch die luft geflogen
teile der trierer innenstadt wurden nach
dem tödlichen vorfall abgesperrt die
rheinland pfälzische ministerpräsident
in malu dreyer äußerte sich entsetzt
über den tödlichen vorfall mit einem
auto in trier und die zahl der opfer
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren